ragazzi ho comprato lo stick e nel
mettersi l'impostore stavo controllando
un coso porca vacca neanche comprare in
santa pace ma porco demonio un attimo
chiuso le porte di elettrica is kill ed
effetto a me mai appoggio cariplo non
potere che noi è fiera subito
ricordiamoci che martina ha beccato nate
adesso martina è morta è nato ha
riportato il corpo io signori non ho
altre prove da ios i ragazzi voglio
infilarmi per aveva i denti la marrone
rosanero chi l'ha visto ma ronde rosa né
adesso guardiamo va bene se riesco a
fare il fix light di elettrica ok no
peace lycra fatto l'ha fatto natal ha
fatto un'altra fatta un'altra fortunata
io cioè il caso di condanna il countdown
cio porco del demonio cioè il cantare
troppo tardi porco demonio nat ci
avevano il countdown a cosa serviva fare
fix light adesso
nat non serviva a niente fare fix light
porco demonio abbiamo il countdown cosa
serve a nessuno mentre per un fix light
a vuoto nuova spreca tempo e questito
forti questi su youtube r fanno i video
su sto gioco maledetto ma porca trottola
dove facciamo march vicino non son
riuscito ucciderlo volevo ucciderlo con
il fix le va bene troppo sotto camere ah
che palle
ancora solo per cento fix light perde
palla finita finita e se ho fatto ma
forse non hanno visto che ora che
comunque quando sono salito a io sono
ancora nessuno l'ora e tu come hai fatto
essere shield che non c'era nessuno non
ho capito niente di quello che ho detto
di non c'era nessuno in shield
io ero a berlino quando c'era fix lights
io stavo facendo quando ci ha visto che
sta facendo uscire
giuro vediamo io ho fatto certi ora non
posso chiaramente light quindi non so
allo ragazzi io provo a fare un po di
security
fai qualcosa ti prego non stai facendo
niente sosta la partita non sta facendo
nulla vietato hp slate mai la pace parte
madonna chi partita inutile
nat ma qualcosa non posso fare tutto io
da impostore nat dove la gente qua non
c'è gente se qualcuno arriva l'uomo non
c'è nessuno ha detto è morto
dopo i portatori andando a fare a vedere
il reattore nel mezzo ho trovato step
tra come si chiama tra fuel e shield io
sto passando di là perché lo so che una
vita ragazzo ori mi ha buttato fuori
gioco infatti si è scomposto davanti
aspetta aspetta è trovato il corpo nella
scomparsa che volevo ucciderla no però
sopra cons come si chiama
dopo la comunicazione si arriva
navigation per il meltdown però eravamo
tutti reactor però lavora noi guardavamo
in realtà mancava solo favier nate pure
si nota detto che gli è sparita ceska
davanti
allora era state report self si sono
messe il report
già perché avevamo effettivamente tutti
il reattore n è vero che era basta il
vero che era abbia fatto abbia ucciso
perché motore atto che cento tutti lì ma
l'avete ucciso di stato quanto che ne so
io no perché sono rimasto sotto e
nessuno mi ha superato i saw passato da
sotto e non che si adoperò ultimato se
non devo riportare non so che dirvi io
ho visto che il secchio
l'unica persona che ho visto non lo so
mi sembra strano perché ho visto che
erano tutti quanti lin erano tutti
quanti li reaktor ho visto più o meno
tattica netta e durante la partita e
nate mille porte anatemi report non mi
dicono non aspetta non sono sicuro che
sia stato nata a riportarmi che non era
nero
e marrone nero e vessicchio quindi sei
nate mi ha pure riportando adesso vado a
rivedermi un orecchio storia pure
piritore era pure vittoria pure victoria
era anche vinto nato da te stavo andando
a vedere la rep
ma tu che hai riportato è sì io ho detto
infamato per tutto il video è zappi vale
ragazzi allora per adesso tutto nella
norma non ho visto nulla di
particolarmente strano secondo me e
bassi questo incredibile web addio e
cesca stanno tutti e due vicino o
potrebbero essere anche entrambi daddy
perfetto allora bisogno della mia
promessa che ho fatto mi girano le
porterò più nient'altro penale per
l'albero perchè ho visto del di uccidere
se non votate in me che son sempre porte
e prenotate prudenti decidete voi
dopo questo l'ho riportato dopo che la
rivista anche sempre io ho visto che vi
meritate di perdere le partite potere la
roma poi dovevano tra i generi fermò a
mangiare pop corn mentre velocità o se
arrivato dopo entrale che canova stavo
seguendo lei che stava andando verso più
e l'ho visto morire male ma visto
l'amico
questo è perché non si nascondono gli
uffici di alfa avrei ho detto che non
avrei più riportato nessuno perché prima
di cazzano scherzo per una questione di
nat che però poi alla fine la ragazza
alla fine la partita è viva la giocato
anche bene nato dopo dopo che sono morto
ha deciso di giocare prima no perché non
giocavano giocavo a giocà dopo dopo dopo
che fa vi è morto si gioca comunque non
fa niente chi se ne frega però io non
riporto più nessuno ha il discorso del
self report francia nostro casinò
il discorso del self report ci sta anche
però io vengo sempre additato quando
faccio sempre porta anche quando non
c'entro nulla e non è giusto non è
giusto quindi è andata così quali prima
io non riporterò mai più nessuno anche
se lo vedo morto non potevano riportare
il corpo di iciar non potevano riportare
ciò che lega non potevano riportare fare
l'impossibile perché ci ha avuto avanti
se non riportarla significherebbe dire
di essere impostore così come di una
achille nola reporting non conta se le
dico orco ecco allora galo in admin l'ho
trovato in questa cosa io è che noi è
nato io vessicchio favi io ve siete
stati e cesca eravamo in elettrica stavo
dicendo scala marina potrebbe essere
pulita per una nuova 15 e si è
sicuramente la marchesa facile
psicologia inversa dicevo di votarla
perché nessuno ha avuto 26 ancora votato
amarti vediamo spiriti davvero io ho
potuto fare
sì è vero ma io lo sapevo benissimo
perché l'abbiamo partita lo sapevo
benissimo eravamo in alpini insieme poi
sono andate le cose non è che il ballet
raga però da dove parte ci piace ma io
pure detto secondo martin e poi tu sei
un pezzo un'area già tagliata
[Musica]